quel est votre principal défaut de
parler beaucoup d'être fouillis
désordonnée pas dans mon travail mais
terriblement dans mes tiroirs et
mais j'ai un hasard extraordinaire parce
que je me retrouve à travers mon désert
je suis pas menteuse
heureusement comme tout le monde mais
pas beaucoup
enfin possible ça m'amuse pas je me
crois de bonne foi
je déteste la mauvaise foi chez les
autres mais dans quelle mesure de
toujours de près une fois soir sur la
raison on croit qu'on est parfois vous
paierez comme des tests chez les autres
de défauts qu'on a soi-même on y décèle
pensions militaires
il ya une forme de complicité à fin mai
j'ai des copains qui a exactement le
même défaut quoi on en a fait des
couples dans la vie abominable à cause
de ça mais on fait des amis
extraordinaire mais pour vous alors
qu'est ce qui est bien pour un marais à
l'art d'être le contraire de vous ac oui
il faut tout il faut être
photo il faut
ne pas voir mes défauts non mais faut
que je puisse admirer et vous pouvez
admirer même quelqu'un que vous
connaissez très très très bien oui si si
chaque fois je suis épaté de nouveau
avec montagne avec bg au canton se
disputent cette dispute
je suis très en colère un triste rappel
puis aussi le sichuan par exemple dans
ces périodes là là je vais m'installer
officiel totalement formule que les
bombes à durban qui m'épate
moi j'ai besoin qu'on me par la frange
entre eux s'intéressent et les risques
bfr et très mouvante avec moi ça me fait
plaisir de vous occuper des gens dont
oui c'est aussi je répète sûrement sur
l'analyse est une forme de dents guérit
pas expliquer ce que montrent en appel
fait que je bouffe les gens saison de
bouffer c'est aussi votre côté sereine
et votre côté mme amara à 6 ans et à
servir comme moi tu l'arrêt par ailleurs
dans le fait de donner de réunion
gens autour de soi il ya aussi le fait
qu'on les profs on les protège oui vous
l'été ça ou ça elle aurait tendance à
bouffer un bouc ou même seulement je
faire bouffer dix ans de cette façon là
c'est quand même pas tellement
désagréable
pourquoi est ce que mon tandis que vous
pouvez les gens riches bilardo
parce que quand vous n'êtes quand on
aime les gens et qu'on s'intéresse
souvient on finit par le des bouffées
parce que est ce que tout ce qui leur
arrive
tout ce qui les embête où tout ce qu'il
a fait plaisir et quand ils voulaient
raconte et bien bout d'un moment où on
entre dans la vie c'est comme ça qu'on
est bouffe on est concerné on est
concerné mais est elle concernée par les
gens c'est aussi appelé dignité afin
d'apprendre des choses mais pas de doute
quand vous avez une idée laquelle vous
venez beaucoup et que vous voulez
essayer de faire partager par quelqu'un
vous préférez convaincre séduire ou
imposer non je cours du jeu très souvent
je ne convainc pas parce que je suis
trop trop agressive et trouver l'homme
qui trouve en tt 1 est embêtante alors
que face à fatiguer j attends pas le but
agressivité mais à cause d'une grande
timidité
si vous êtes une personne timide et des
gens qui ne l'aiment pas du tout je sais
même qui le détestent parce que comment
un côté terriblement
j'avais qualité via l'appli la tigresse
oui l attaque parce qu'elle a peur
d'être affiché l attaque parce qu'elle a
placé le mans c'est le personnage depuis
extraordinaire que j'ai obtenu ma vie
sur le plan de la fidélité dans l'amitié
on va les colères terribles tanks de
tout ordre aussi bien sur le domaine
artistique dans le maine politique de la
vie de tout court j'ai vu pendez-les et
des colères puis pied on est lui dans
l'histoire d'ailleurs comme ça souvent
moi mais ça fait rien parce que ouais
c'était peut-être un peu exagéré mais
dans 90% des cas là verizon avait dit
mais je suis très agressif sauf avec mon
temps ça m'a touché en même temps ça m'a
étonné parce que beaucoup de gens sont
contraints très agressif avec les gens
qu'ils aiment une telle de même entendu
me dire quelque chose d'extrêmement
désagréable et que a priori je n'ai pas
appris comme vous l'avez le progrès
c'est moi je fais fâché et alors 7
qu'est ce que ça fait plaisir aussi
enseignant puis oui pour ça et puis
maintenant c'est exactement si on dirait
mettre à l'école répond pas moi je
réponds pas quand il est mais en vingt
ans
tous les êtres humains en pleine de
cailloux de se décevoir se faire du mal
de se réconcilier le disputer de ces sms
qui veut pas dire qu'on se marie
consommé du lait qu'on savait
bien sûr mais enfin tu as aussi c'est
formidable de pouvoir se dire qu'on est
passé à travers tout ça j'ai pour mes
amis finalement les mêmes réactions et
de jalousie de position que pour les
âmes diplômés de jalousie est bien sûr
mais il a oublié salariés défaut oui
mais sa forme de jalousie
c'est là devrait épater la jalousie me
passait quelque chose que vous aviez
dépassé qu'est ce qui dépasse jamais
scène en à distance dans le fond ce
serait très embêtant avec un monsieur
qui plaisent à personne il ya aussi une
forme alors que c'est là où la salle de
la possession il vient enfin minablement
suis plus là c'est de se dire il vous
plait bien
il est à moi l'install propriété encore
non mais ferme que bernard quelqu'un qui
plaît bien et de courir des risques
puis bon c'est imaginons que demain tu
arrives tu ménages y arrive j'aurai
tellement de choses tél
je parle comme ça maintenant et je me
comporterai pas bien du tout point du
tout savoir comment sont en train d'en
impunis kanna mène mais j'aurais eu même
temps formidable de 20 ans - ma ville et
a refait competo depuis la naissance
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on refait tout bas y
compris les bêtises
[Musique]